waouh pourquoi cet objet tourner et bien
en donner une impulsion il va tourner
sur lui même ce qui fait que la france
refuse de s'effacer de nos noces
manstein ozman je t'aime aujourd'hui on
va parler sion soit prêt mais on va
faire du coup plus con mais qui plairait
quand même à dr bossman pour échanger
qui s'appelle i done foulques et c'est
l'un des premiers jeux auxquels tu as
joué devant dans ta vie et oui
l'habitude ne sait pas encore c'est le
jeu où tu un dessin immense il faut
trouver certains éléments dans le dessin
voilà un jeu vidéo qui est sorti c'est
sûr ça oui j'ai 7 ans et demi dans ma
tête et alors j'ai pas encore je voulais
attendre cette vidéo pour y jouer c'est
tout c'est de la merde
sassou ça pue la merde à mon avis ça pue
pas la merde et surtout l'évolution va
être ou genre là au début c'est un tout
petit dessin donc je pense qu'à la fin
ça va être un dessin immense on va
passer huit ans il me tue pour trouver
un [ __ ] de serpents ça être la merde
comment ça un champ d'un dessin ici on a
les trois éléments qu'on doit trouver et
ya là vraiment un [ __ ] de sa pas à
trouver et l'acquis qui le singent aime
les abris bien douillet qui c'est un
prénom de chiens ce singe d'être
malheureux à partir doit déjà la voilà
c'est l'huile et la danse pas lui
annonce palu [ __ ] ya plusieurs singes
mais quand je connais qui dézone il aime
les abris bien douillet à partir de là
il est ou kiki où il ya un abri bien
douillet l'ars
c'est lui c'est qu'il ya ça j'aime bien
avoir tout se passe pas bien sur cette
île se passe un truc alors ce gros
serpent aux roms dans les buissons dans
des buissons n'y en a pas partout un et
je trouve quand même pas je suis je pue
la merde y'a pas de huisseau [ __ ] il
n'y a pas de [ __ ] ça au déjà du câble
a invoqué à tort ça c'est les buissons
banane blanche avait trouvé banane
blanche que j'ai trouvé nickel c'était
prévu c'est fait exprès magique j'ai je
sais même pas où ils étaient entre dans
la jungle alors mecs savent à peu au
delà pour milan je peux zoomer wesh
pezou mais oh là là mais mec non mais on
enfin la difficulté on va jouer un jeu
résout ce calcul tu as trouvé quatre
c'est ça maintenant un peu plus dur
résout ce calcul là alors mec c'est
abusé vraiment c'est abusé ça n'a pas de
sens de faire ça enfin vraiment l'a61
confortable et le dernier des soucis
déjà c'est un mec comme ça donc c'est
lui c'est lui
[Musique]
ok il y en a un deuxième si tu veux la
vie de jesse la classe les siestes en
haut d'un arbre c'est ce qu'il ya de
mieux donc c'est un mec qui dort en haut
d'un arbre
les paladares mais aussi assez des
arbres ça d'accord je n'ai pas calé six
mois si je suis tellement fort en d5 et
qu'on sait pas assez bien fait j'arrive
pas avoir faim c'est au jeu trouver un
point dans son box va c'est énorme ça
m'arrive tous les jours des fois je
touche je tombe sur un bandage pas grand
chose à cacher et rivières les armes
avec c'est tellement des fourbes je suis
obligé de détruire l'environnement juste
pour trouver des gens c'est incroyable
et le singe volant en fait je clique sur
des trucs j'ai l'impression de voir les
noms je pense qu'on va procéder comme ça
sera plus simple nouvelles zones
débloquer alors pour y aller en
profondeur la guitare est en pleine
conversation avec la balançoire bas elle
est là près de l'arbre et de la whey
même fx à cannes les la meuf allongé est
là dedans non et dans une tente voilà
probablement ici et ça c'est quoi sa
brosse à cheveux habitants se trouve
avec tapas n'ont aucun sens au bordel de
merde mais mais j'en ai pour huit années
c'est bon cette vidéo va y avait duré 10
heures vraiment arias quoi et un
apiculteur mail qui joue avec des
papillons et jouer avec une arme qui
glace les gens et d'enfants y compris
mais ouvert au match c'est énorme c'est
on est dans le futur une banane une
truffe un lapin qui est caché dans un
trou il ya des as mais ça c'est le coin
des abeilles c'est des ruches donc ici
logiquement donné par l'huile à
l'apiculteur c'est lui yes son
agriculteur c'est énorme
ok ensuite elle elle joue avec des
papillons aux ailes des papillons là y'a
des papillons elle doit être pas là oui
c'est le bûcheron bien sûr bien c'est
lui qu'on cherchait n'était pas eu à me
ficherais papillon le comex et du résumé
des papillons quelque part dites moi
tout est le moins aulas mais ça va loin
à ici bas voilà ici c'est le coin
papillon énorme mais qui des zooms lundi
avec repérer les papilles tout comme on
les appelle au caire et pikachu il est à
côté du seul point est fait du camping
le seul point est fait du camping max et
ce bruitage plus jamais assez là où il
ya des enceintes et où c'est sûr c'est
la mecque c'est sur celle là on va voir
tout les temps je m'en bats les couilles
jamais les gens je veux trouver pikachu
un fermier une fourche est une fleur
rare ok facile aux plats la fleur rare
elle est là fermiers il manque juste la
fourche ou à la fourche alors mec la
fourche la ya un vrai délire sous le
truc de [ __ ] hockey est ce que vous
êtes prêts pour une nouvelle mission
extraordinaire
alors c'est parti mon page mes lunettes
de hackers ch pas pourquoi tu t'es un
mec c'est le pire jeu pour m'aider
lunettes du coup je vois rien c'était un
antique esprit natifs américains
soudainement pris possession down le
garde forestier et qu'est ce que ça veut
dire qu'est ce que tu fais comme un
authentique esprit natifs américains
proposition de ton corps ah [ __ ] c'est
un indice mais je ne serai pas décrypté
chu de merde
les temps de faire entrer dans la tête
de newton de la physique qui porte ses
fruits ok d'après harry du bétail à
vizille et toujours du bétail
ok aiguille n'est pas dans une botte de
foin mais elle sait comment on roule ok
ensuite on a un cadavres de poissons un
taureau un épouvantail haut de forme et
choc le poulet mec alors au revoir c'est
parti ok les pauvres ça il fallait faire
pousser du blé pour qu'il apparaisse
excellent ok le taureau qui était dans
un emploi désolé j'ai même pas le temps
de vous prévenir parce que je clic sans
savoir si ça va être ça ou pas et attend
mec moi je vais retrouver ce [ __ ] de
public s'est enfui la sono clos les là
il peut pas être bien loin ce [ __ ] de
poulet il est où ce poulet et disent
qu'il est allé la pièce dérobée sont
plus tard vous l'avez pas vu et voyons
ce point certains cas vous a plu ces cas
n'hésitez pas à aller mais comme david
mec c'est sérieux d'abord une frappe
aussi grande je peux pas plus des zooms
et c'est horrible chef totaux étaient
encore debout une minute plus tôt au
kenya un indien qui va mal à trouver le
mec qui va aller au festival mais les
panneaux ne l'aide pas à la dengue qui
servent sur les vents légers à travers
le désert un cactus une plante une
lunette de la femme que les trois autour
n'ont pas mangé
oh là là ok bon c'est parti je te jure
que j'en ai pour la nuit mais je veux au
moins tout le cactus parce que je voyais
un cactus qu'un chapeau c'est super cool
vélo le cactus [ __ ] j'ai envie de me
flinguer
même mon corps est fait une allergie la
[ __ ] si quelqu'un a vu le cactus qui
avait un chapeau et ne me l'a pas dit
alors là je vais lui en vouloir à tout
jamais un jour je ferai à prévenir un
[ __ ] mec c'est la plus grosse en quête
de ma life je prends ce jeu beaucoup
trop au sérieux comme tous les jeux
auquel joue en ce moment je n'accepterai
jamais et échoué à cette épreuve est de
voir derrière des gens qui protestent
de la vidéo et qui entourent tel objet
que j'ai pas vu pendant que je tournais
mais regarde il était là le cactus ce
scénario n'arrivera jamais parce que je
vais me battre et je vais try hard
[Musique]
i'm so fucking api et ben les amis cette
fois c'est vraiment la fin de la vidéo
n'hésitez pas à aller mais si elle vous
a plu les où est charlie comme ça c'est
pour moi indémodable c'est trop bien par
contre tu te prends tellement d'infos à
la seconde que tu ailles même pu avoir
des trucs basiques qui s'est trop
coûteux contours d'un rajout à jouer
avec vous comme si on avait sept ans et
demi finalement et qu'on faisait une
petite pyjama party c'est bon elle les a
mis aux prises deux prochaines vidéos et
n'oubliez pas en faisant ceux ci ont
créé une poussée l'objet de cette
manière d'agir en faisant appel aux
mannes
[Musique]